and uh that's so true I don't care
that's like like I want I I wanted to
[ __ ] do a parody of J station like
way back like in July yeah but like I
just wanted to go all out like put it on
like a spooky channel just full up
parody it just characterize him like to
the fullest huh and just have it like
like actual scary [ __ ] happening so cuz
like his deadpan delivery is I was just
like oh my gosh guys there's something
really frightening going and I wanted to
do that and then just actually like like
the cut I imagine was being like oh my
gosh guys this place is so scared we
better make sure the lights work and
just like turn it on in a bedroom and
there's just a the scariest thing you've
ever seen in that bedroom and then I
turned them off and turn them back on
again and I look and he's not there I'm
like oh my gosh it's definitely haunted
in here you guys oh my gosh good thing
the lights are on
otherwise I'd be very scared right now
it's something mark Wiens yeah pretty
much
and then that wait to scare you guys
wait to sue years so scary so scary so
many ghosts and I'm nursing a ghost like
this ever my entire life and we just
scared you guys I wanted to do it all
with like like straight up like rapper
chains like a brick squad chain off
white like the most obnoxious [ __ ] just
like just a full-on how you know that's
the most obnoxious [ __ ] ever $20,000
outfit hunting ghosts he's scary in here
you guys it's like the height beast of
ghostbusters they've got they got
[ __ ] supreme guns or whatever the
[ __ ] what I do as much was having their
hands did this is made by supreme it's
the whole thing's red supreme logos all
over it
oh man gosh guys we'd better catch these
monsters and they open up like a little
device they put on the floor that like
opens up to yes the monster yeah they
just open it's just full of money like
better get this out of here yes or puts
it in like his [ __ ] supreme like man
stuffing it in there you take he wearing
he's wearing a murse and he opens it up
and he's got a fanny pack inside the
murse
and he puts on the fanny pack and opens
that what's the money under there it's
the money in there just so much designer
on designer [ __ ] man you guys I think I
just saw ghost goes down and opens up
the louisv trunk Supreme gun oh my god
that's like his next video is like what
I hunt ghosts with yeah it's just a
Superflex just just designer like the
craziest designer [ __ ] basically the
song we're writing yeah yeah yeah which
we need to finish by the way I was just
think about that this morning I actually
wrote to that the other day you really
yeah yeah I've been chalmers kind of
okay yeah but it'll be ready soon um
anyway yeah I don't know where I was
going with that but oh no no yeah that
hunts the ghost of John Versace or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah yeah that's the
duty got murdered right oh I don't know
you know [ __ ] those Versace man like
that was a documentary about it yeah
yeah isn't that the guy that got
murdered
Versace I think it is I'll just he's
gonna he's gonna hunt that go snacks
yeah well what's the one I wanted to do
is like in the bit like climbing into a
wraith mm-hmm like alright guys thank
you so much I'm really spooked out right
cuz what ghosts huh a ghost
phantom Wraith Phantom isn't our ghost
I don't think so yeah horse ghosts mmm
am i tripping I'm gonna feel weird if
this isn't true I don't know I'm not
gonna pretend like I'm really familiar
with rolls-royce models come on Cody
hold on guys is that oh yeah yeah
there's a ghost yeah when that make more
sense yeah yeah ago
do you get it yeah I do because it's
spooky yeah because it's spooky
yeah and it's he's hunting ghosts yeah
so he'd have a ghost if you look at like
the end of every Jay Station video he
always plugs the SUBSCRIBE call to
action as he's running away okay oh my
gosh guys I might die right now uh
please subscribe like it's like that
dramatic it's like it's like the kids
first ball that makes no sense right
yeah because it's like oh my god I'm so
scared I might die please subscribe it's
like well you're gonna die there's no
real point employee it's like the kids
that you see the kids that were like
faking their own death yeah and they
went to a chiropractor okay so there's
this video by Leon lush where he watches
these these like to Australian kids who
have a gaming channel and it's basically
like the views were dwindling they had
like 4 million subscribers but they're
getting like a hundred thousand views on
their videos right something like that
so to like beef up their views they
basically did this video where they're
both sitting in from the camera talking
about how they have to quit YouTube
because they're both dying and dying
from like weird he's like he's got
kidney disease he I don't know I just
wake up with pain every day and that's
called you're going through puberty
let's go
oh my get your teething dog my teeth
hurt and your teething that's what it is
growing in my teeth are falling out I'm
[ __ ] actually eight years old I've
been German Button disease reversing
yeah he was basically like it was it was
some [ __ ] you'd hear like a senior
citizen say he was like I just feel
shitty I think my body is just
deteriorating it's like dude you're 14
yeah I mean I mean first of all and I'm
not like it's it's very clearly faking
it and it turns out to be fake that's
why we're able to be they were actually
dying we wouldn't know saying this [ __ ]
not like chorus so then so then the
whole thing the whole thing ends up in
them flying to America and visiting I
don't know if you guys have seen this
like chiropractors have channels on
YouTube yeah really weird yeah it's
really weird but think about doing a
video
because it's like it's like it's a huge
trend right now chiropractic offices I'd
have to have YouTube channels a lot of
medical offices have YouTube channels no
but I mean now that like not like
chiropractor doctors right that's why
they're allowed to do it cuz they can
show they're like mmm yeah yeah they're
like patient care and stuff like that
because it's not under like ya duress or
whatever it is that's what I mean by
medical yeah it's there yeah there are a
lot of weird like non unofficial yeah
for like medical practice yeah the
chiropractors help you can feel no I
know they do but it like it just feels
sketchy watching someone else putting
their back adjusted it's like I'm
watching like a medical procedure why
are you yeah why is this on yeah and
it's so funny cuz all like these
Instagram models will go to these
doctors yeah and they'll show up in
sports bra and yoga pants sick and the
thumbnail is like them sitting on a you
know like a doctor's bench or whatever
like face down and her ass is popping up
and it's like those are the most popular
ones and always some like creep sitting
there like getting their rocks off to
this girl getting her back adjusted like
spare parts are porn
you mean the chiropractor what he's the
one getting his rocks off you guys back
issues yeah it's really it's really
really bizarre so anyways these two kids
go and see one of these guys I guess the
whole the whole thing is that they're
both trying to promote each other's
channels right so weird first of all how
the [ __ ] did that conversation even
happen how did this weird old
chiropractor in America find these two
gaming youtubers in Australia and hit
them up for a collab what the [ __ ] was
that
I mean I don't know I mean YouTube's the
interesting voice and then for them to
be like here's our idea we're thinking
about faking our own deaths I know it
was and then we come to you and we get
an adjustment and we're all good I know
to what what was it he was like you guys
are hot
my name is pastor Sean but I run a I'm
just kidding that's a blanket statement
[Music]
[Music]
these are nothing